if you're feeling a little stuck you're
in good company so many of the Disney
Princesses live their lives in isolation
keep watching to find out how they coped
with extreme social distancing and how
they broke free against all odds
[Music]
we'll start with the most obvious Disney
Princess no one experienced isolation
quite like Rapunzel from tangled
Rapunzel was the Princess of Corona
Mother Gothel stole her away when she
was just a baby and locked her in a
tower the only person she ever
interacted with was Gothel at least
Aurora and Sleeping Beauty had the
fairies to keep her company
Gotha would also be gone for long
periods of time so Rapunzel had to
entertain herself she had isolation down
to an art she spent time drawing and
painting baking and playing darts
playing guitar and reading she even took
up hobbies like ventriloquist lis the
song when will my life begin sounds like
a great checklist for boredom eventually
Rapunzel convinced Flynn Rider to take
her to see the lanterns but what's
interesting is that she planned to
return originally then she discovered
how awful Mother Gothel was another
princess who lived in extreme isolation
was Aurora this was for her safety
however her parents knew that she was in
isolation so they weren't worried about
her whereabouts
the fairies raised Aurora to believe
that they were her hands and not magical
they are just trying to hide her from
Maleficent and the less she knows the
better she doesn't have a grand
adventure like Rapunzel though she
pricks her finger on her 16th birthday
when she ventures away from the cottage
Philip manages to save her there was
another princess who was kept in
isolation for her own good Jasmine's
father was terrified of letting her out
of the palace we understand his concern
but this was completely unnecessary he
wasn't protecting her from an evil fairy
like Aurora's parents he was just too
paranoid this might feel very familiar
but we don't recommend dealing with
isolation the way Jasmine did she snuck
out of the palace and got into some
serious trouble but thankfully Aladdin
came to her aid in the live-action movie
we also learned that Jasmine loved
reading books and looking at maths it
was how she explored the world that's
why the magic carpet ride was the real
way to her heart she just wanted to see
the world
has a lot in common with Princess
Jasmine mallanna's father was also very
protective he was so scared of losing
anyone to the ocean that he prohibited
his people from venturing off the island
but their people were born explorers
their whole culture had been built
around ocean exploration lalana was
called to the sea from a very young age
when she found to the heart of Taif ET
when the curse of taffy dee began to
affect the food supply for her people
she decided she had had enough she snuck
off the island and found the demigod
Maui she was a natural at sealing and
she was able to save not just her
village but her entire culture Moana and
Jasmine aren't the only princesses who
craved adventure Belle always felt
trapped in her poor provincial town she
used books as an escape in the
live-action movie she was also an
inventor that's a great way to pass the
time but she wanted more from life she
wanted an adventure Belle got that when
she went to save her father then she
ended up trapped in a whole new way but
we'll cover that later tactically
vanellope von schweetz
is a Disney Princess too in Ralph's
breaks the internet she said she felt
trapped in her game she had done the
same things over and over again she was
thrilled to be on an Internet adventure
she was much happier once she joined
slaughter race
Penelope just needed a change of pace to
feel less isolated
wait princess vanellope von schweetz
many of the princesses end up trapped
either because they are cursed or has
some sort of punishment
Belle is one example she went from being
trapped in a boring town to being
trapped in an enchanted castle but she
allowed herself to be isolated willingly
to save her father
that's pretty noble if you ask us the
beasts kept her confined first to her
room and then to the castle at large but
when she tried to escape and he saved
her from the wolves she went back
willingly fans have debated this over
and over but it seems like everything
she did was of her own accord like
other princesses bow spent her captivity
reading she was equipped with an epic
library after all the castle is your
home now so you can go anywhere you like
except the West Wing what's in the West
it's forbidden Cinderella is yet another
Disney princess who is trapped as
punishment
her stepmother forced her to stay with
them and work as their servant
Cinderella passed her time cleaning and
sewing she wasn't free to do anything
else
once her stepmother figured out she was
the mysterious woman from the ball
she took the isolation one step further
she locked Cinderella in the Attic
thankfully her fairy godmother and mice
friends helped her escape and she got to
live her happily ever after Megara from
Hercules on the other hand was kept
captive by the god of the underworld
Hades at the beginning of the movie we
find out that she is trapped in a deal
with Hades she's one of his minions and
he has a plan to overthrow Zeus how did
she end up in this deal well she did
something Noble just like Belle only it
didn't turn out so well she tried to
save her ex by offering her soul for his
but he left her for another woman
yikes Meg ends up further trapped in the
underworld later in the movie her soul
is in danger of not being rescued
thankfully Hercules dives into the river
Styx to save her Tiana from Princess and
the Frog
also ended up magically trapped she got
herself turned into a frog by kissing
one how'd I get way down here and all
the time
[Music]
that's not how that story was supposed
to go right just like Meg Tiana never
wanted a grand adventure these two
definitely stand out from the other
princesses med wanted someone she loved
to be saved
Tiana just wanted her hard work to pay
off so she could have her own restaurant
but Tiana got a huge adventure she and
Prince Naveen had to figure out how to
undo dr. facili as voodoo curse she
saved New Orleans from the voodoo master
and bagged herself a prince in the
process she was even willing to stay as
a frog to be with him that's something
else she and Meg have in common they
would do anything for their significant
other Tiana was trapped in the body of a
frog but other princesses have ended up
trapped in actual objects let's take a
look at Ariel she didn't grow up in
isolation she was one of seven
princesses she could go anywhere in her
father's Kingdom but she never felt like
she belonged that sort of loneliness is
its own type of isolation she spent her
time watching humans and collecting
human items it's a pretty cool hobby for
a mermaid but all Ariel wanted was to be
part of the human world so she took
matters into her own hands and ended up
being trapped in an even worse situation
she got involved in a deal with the sea
witch Ursula Ursula then trapped
Ariel's voice in a seashell Ariel's
isolation might be different from the
other princesses but it was still
isolation she was put in the human world
with no boys she didn't know a lot and
she couldn't communicate at all have we
met I knew it
Anna and Elsa have been trapped in an
object too they both ended up trapped in
ice but we'll cover that in a few
minutes let's look at their extreme
social distancing first Elsa's powers
might not be a curse but she sure felt
like they were as a kid after she
accidentally hit Anna with the ice her
parents kept her isolated they did it to
protect her just like Aurora's parents
and Jasmine's father but this had
lasting effects for both onna and Elsa
Elsa spent most of her time in her room
she wouldn't even play with honor
she was also isolated because she was
the only one with these powers she spent
her life punishing herself but that hurt
Anna even more on a past her time
talking to paintings and riding her bike
in the hallways she just wanted a
playmate but she had no one that's why
she was so trusting of everyone she met
including Hans
she was just desperate for human
connection they both felt even more
isolated after their parents were lost
at sea they didn't lean on each other at
all for support
once Elsa's powers were out in the open
she took her isolation one step further
she wanted to live on her own in an ice
castle she could be herself without
hurting Anna or anyone else but Anna
wouldn't have it when Anna tried to save
her she ended up being frozen completely
this was the magical object that she was
trapped in else's love saved her and
thawed her frozen heart a similar thing
happened to Elsa in frozen - she went to
aughtta Hollin alone but she went too
far she ended up frozen in ice all alone
but Anna was able to save arendelle and
the north older tribe her selflessness
broke the spell and freed Elsa these two
sisters have experienced every type of
isolation but they learn to overcome it
together the vast majority of Disney
princesses have experienced some sort of
isolation or captivity even Snow White
the first princess was somewhat isolated
in the castle she was all alone until
she fled from the Huntsman and met the
Seven Dwarves Disney has even carried
this isolation theme into the Disney
Channel
Evie mal and all the V case from
descendants spent their childhoods in
isolation on the Isle of the Lost
in fact there
really only three princesses that
weren't isolated Mulan Pocahontas and
Merida never ended up trapped so why
does Disney use this theme over and over
again
well it's something that is relatable to
everyone we don't mean actual isolation
although it seems like everyone
understands that these days but
isolation makes people lonely and
loneliness is something everyone has
experienced people can relate to feeling
lost and alone you might even feel
trapped when you don't have many options
even the three princesses who didn't end
up an actual isolation felt isolated by
not fitting in that's another universal
human experience it makes all of the
princesses feel real and relatable but
all of their stories ended with a
happily ever after there's a lot to
learn from all of these princesses first
they all found ways to pass the time
they all realized what was really
important to them and they found their
happy endings by leaning on other people
which princess do you identify with the
most let us know in the comments thanks
for watching give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
we'll see you next time on the themes
[Music]
you